[Risas]
[Música]
bueno lo primero que les quiero decir es
que nos gustan sus parlantes o sus
audífonos o el acento que escuchan es
venezolano yo soy venezolano pero
también soy ecuatoriano quiero contarles
una historia una historia que me contó
mi hijo más
cuando yo tenía como ocho o nueve años
los recuerdos del pasado con el presente
se sobreponen cuando ella tenía nueve
años ella micro desde quito su ciudad
natal hacia venezuela con mi abuela se
montaron en un autobús y cuatro días
después estaban en caracas
de esas primeras experiencias en caracas
ellas se alojaron en un motel en el
centro mi abuela un día tuvo que hacer
unas diligencias y dejó a mi mamá
viendo televisión adaptándose a ese
nuevo acento esa nueva cultura a ese
nuevo país cuando ya regreso le trajo de
comer una arepa rellena con huevos
revueltos y una malta este fue en el
momento en el que yo me enamoré de
venezuela me dijo mi mamá una imagen que
ella conserva desde hace 44 años 44 años
mi mamá tiene viviendo en venezuela un
país que ella ahora considera suyo
hace 4 años cuando yo me creé desde
caracas hasta quitó mientras estábamos
en el terminal de autobuses
entre abrazos y lágrimas jugadas mi mamá
me dijo que yo tenía que conseguir esa
imagen que me hiciera enamorarme de
ecuador- así como lo hizo ella
para mí fue sencillo fue la paz
y la certeza de que en este país podría
fundar las bases de un futuro prometedor
a través de mi historia de tu historia
podemos tener algo muy claro migrar es
un derecho y eso es algo que no me estoy
inventando eso es algo que me estoy
sacando del sombrero como los magos lo
hacen con sus conejos eso está
establecido en la declaración universal
de los derechos humanos en sus artículos
13 14 y 15 artículo 13 derecho a la
libertad de movimiento
artículo 14 derecho al asilo artículo 15
derecho a la nacionalidad también está
establecido en el pacto mundial de
migración creado por las naciones unidas
en 2018 y firmado por 164 países
según datos del alto comisionado para
las naciones unidas- de los refugiados
en 2020 habían 79.5 millones de personas
fuera de sus hogares por persecución
conflictos sociales o violaciones a los
derechos humanos de esa cantidad de
personas 45 puntos 7 millones eran
desplazados internos 29 puntos 6
millones
william de su país natal principalmente
refugiados 4.2 millones eran
solicitantes de asilo
ustedes se recuerdan de esas imágenes de
los procesos migratorios de los
ecuatorianos para finales de 2019 habían
1.183.000 685 ecuatorianos fuera del
país ustedes recuerdan a las madres los
padres los hermanos las hermanas los
hijos las hijas despidiendo a los
ecuatorianos desde la verja desde la
reja que rodeaba al aeropuerto
internacional en quito
europa y eeuu le abrieron las puertas a
estas personas
la mayoría de los ecuatorianos hoy en
día dentro de su familia puede trazar a
un migrante tiene una experiencia
migratoria
y ante eso tenemos que conseguir tenemos
que encontrar entonces la verdad en los
siguientes números
para 2021 para inicios de 2021 habían
5.6 millones de venezolanos migrantes y
refugiados es la segunda migración
mundial después de los sirios y américa
del sur se ha convertido en el eje
central de este desplazamiento colombia
con 1.7 millones de venezolanos perú con
un millón 50 mil venezolanos chile con
457 mil y ecuador con 431 mil con
proyecciones saque final a finales de
2021 seamos más de medio millón de
venezolanos viviendo en ecuador con la
cantidad de venezolanos que hay en el
mundo de inmigrantes y refugiados
venezolanos que en el mundo
podríamos abarcar casi tres veces a la
población de quito con los venezolanos
que hoy en día viven en ecuador
podríamos llenar 12 veces el estadio
olímpico atahualpa
siete veces el estadio monumental en
guayaquil o 650 veces el teatro nacional
sucre
pero estos números estas cifras son más
que datos en un reporte semestral o
anual
son más que números
son historias que tenemos que contar y
que tenemos que ver a través de la
empatía sin burocracia porque emigrar
básicamente es eso un ejercicio de
empatía un ejercicio de humanidad y
tenemos que entender cuáles son los
diferentes contextos que hacen que una
persona migra qué es lo que hace que una
persona se monta en una patera en un
bote improvisado y cruzar mediterráneo
desde áfrica a europa que es lo que hace
que una persona camine por 15 o 20 días
a través de 4 países 34 países con sus
familiares y las pocas pertenencias que
tiene encima
yo les voy a contar una historia y una
de las primeras veces que yo recorrí
quito con mi esposa y mi hijo mayor nos
metimos en una panadería en una pequeña
panadería y la muchacha que nos atendió
reconoció nuestro acento y nos contó su
historia de migración nos dijo que ella
también había migrado a los eeuu desde
cuenca y que entendía nuestra
experiencia que entendía por lo que
nosotros estábamos pasando y nos daba la
bienvenida a su hogar hogar una palabra
que se repite muchísimas veces en las
historias de los migrantes en las
experiencias de los migrantes
hogar es una palabra que también se ha
repetido en mi experiencia como migrante
recuerdo que una vez llegando por el
aeropuerto internacional mariscal sucre
de quito la muchacha de emigración veía
mi pasaporte ecuatoriano y me veía me
veía mi pasaporte ecuatoriano y me veía
a mí y tras unos segundos de ese baile
me dice tú no pareces ecuatoriano
yo no supe cómo reaccionar me agarró
como decimos en venezuela- fuera de base
ella tomó las riendas de la situación y
con una sonrisa bastante pícara me dijo
pero eso no importa eso en realidad no
importa bienvenido a tu hogar y me selló
el pasaporte
esta es experiencia de empatía esas
demostraciones de empatía son las que
tenemos que potenciar porque los
migrantes no pierden la dignidad cuando
cruzan las fronteras no se convierten en
ciudadanos de tercera o cuarta categoría
ese es nuestro llamado a la acción desde
cualquier espacio en el que estemos ya
sea con nuestros familiares en nuestro
hogar ya sea en nuestro trabajo con
nuestros compañeros de trabajo ya sea
nuestro entorno académico en la
universidad en el colegio no podemos
permitir que se potencien narrativas
discriminatorias en torno a la disco en
torno a la migración
si nosotros tenemos nuestro contexto y
nuestro contraste vivo de lo que ha sido
la migración ecuatoriana tenemos las
herramientas para luchar contra esas
narrativas discriminatorias no solo en
torno a la migración sino a lo que
afecta a nuestra humanidad entonces
veamos a estas personas veamos a estos
migrantes vamos a darles una mano vamos
a ayudarlos para que consigan esas
imágenes y esas sensaciones que los
hagan enamorarse de los países de
acogida así como lo hizo mi mamá hace 44
años así como lo hiciste tú cuando mi
gran cuando migrantes o así como lo
hicieron tus familiares cuando emigraron
así como lo hice yo
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]